buenas tardes chicos a la 1
esta imagen fue tomada en el año 2006
por la sonda de drogas cassini él el de
peter camino frágil al sistema de
lunas de júpiter júpiter tiene muchas lunas
con potencial de habitabilidad y ser
un potencial de tal vez para encontrar vida
en esos lo que soy centro americano y
latinoamericano tiene en el chamanismo y tu
ni de labranza indígena lo que otros
se detendría pero la pregunta era y
como si estas dependencias curaran el
Los indios eran excelentes navegantes.
si pudieras mirar al cielo y clasificar las
la mayoría de estas estrellas lo que pude
hacer bien el concepto de astrobiología
astrobiología la ciencia que estudia el
pasado el presente y el futuro de la vida en el
universo
así que aquí es siempre donde tenemos que
vida solo en la tierra
partiendo de esta idea al principio
copérnico copérnico cree que tiene
muchos planetas con vida pero porque yo
Decidí estudiar esto es en el año 2009
nuestra misión que es romper
a kepler y y buscar planetas o
exoplanetas
¿Alguien ha oído hablar de los exoplanetas?
puede puede complacer pocos buenos solo para
sabes que el que predice encontró dos mil
seiscientos y tantos planetas pero ahora
que tipo de que planeta sera ese
planetas similares a la tierra el planeta como
tendrán condiciones similares bajo
habitabilidad
pero como entonces como es que yo por ejemplo
aquí estaba mi propuesta o idea
dentro de los días de seguimiento y tengo esta idea
de poder atrapar la luz 2 el planeta
en realidad la estrella que cruza el
la atmósfera del planeta a través de un
eclipse fue el método
y aquí para el alma y esta luz tiene
informacion muy valiosa sin esa luz
¿Puede darnos el espectro de ese sonido es el dedo?
imprimir son las lineas que nos pueden decir
si este cerca del planeta tiene elementos
¿Qué tipo de elementos químicos pueden incluso
puede tener elementos de agua
interesante en términos de química
orgánico bueno como empecé a estudiar tiene
varios temas entre estas pruebas del dia
y uno de ellos es zaha exoplanet vitality
área les presenta el índice de
semejanza con los planetas que importan
están actualmente dentro de 0.8 y 1 debe ser
que teniamos que enseñar totem
de planetas para poder buscar y
investiga este aspecto y presenta las
recetario de cocina para pensar
en un planeta habitable tenemos que tener un
fuente de energía 12 un solvente
universal es que es agua y tres elementos
químicos para hacer lo que hice aquí en
la tierra crea la creación y la formación de esa
química prebiótica para tener planetas
ahora el tipo de tierra y no el tipo de teleférico es
tipo de escuchar las ubicaciones de los actores
pero cual es la idea del sistema de
habitabilidad es el concepto de
habitabilidad
se ve simple, así que el planeta está en eso
zona la habitabilidad una región donde el
el agua líquida puede estar en la superficie
pero en realidad este es un concepto muy
multiparámetros más complejos que tienen
relaciones en este entorno y planetario
mi sueño es si esta imagen fue tomada
por las marcas francesas de way the sea
tener con el espectrómetro de los océanos
los continentes de la tierra
mi sueño era encontrar esa línea que dice
el héroe pero en el planeta exeter afuera
lejos de la tierra que hice
presenta parte de mi investigación es
para poder recopilar varios parámetros
quien hablo de esa zona
habitabilidad de marketing y venus y
pon el mío en el gráfico seleccionando
top ten de los planetas y piensa bien donde
con aquí el parámetro que tenemos que
encontrar en relación con la temperatura que hay y
el flujo de la estrella incidente en este
planeta no pude encontrar las lineas
al revés pero vemos que nombre el siguiente
centauro b
este exoplaneta es uno de los más habitables
o un dios pero potencialmente habitable
pero el esta a 4.6 años luz de la tierra es el
más cercano que no tomaría como 100 mil
años de llegar
con la tecnología actual 2015 fue
interesante tuve un ataque
decidir porque apenas ingresó a la física y
ser capaz de trabajar con acciones domésticas
uno de los mejores diarios del
astronomía astronáutica allí a un sitio web y
pero también es recuperación con trabajo
con el polo astronómico de Casimir
hijo de montenegro pero también para ver dos
conversaciones interesantes con rigor
de los vicepresidentes de los Estados Unidos
entrenando en rio de janeiro y el
presentó este concepto de los cambios
clima sino también como yo era el
Heroe de la infancia
los puentes de marcos era exactamente
que paró hace cuatro años
ahí sentada estás tú, pregunta
así que mientras tu legado
otro legado tuyo para el proximo
generaciones
Estaba sentado allí llorando por ser
un drama mexicano tiene un hijo de
la vida pensó ok estoy investigando el
planetas pero agrandandose y de cierta manera
malditas bolsas pero que de verdad yo
Me voy de aqui y donde estoy
se detuvo en bonn
El agua fue fundamental en el origen de
Vida en la Tierra
pero como es el futuro siendo presente
en realidad el planeta agua
entonces comencé a entender bien si el agua
y el núcleo y este motor del sistema en
la habitabilidad planetaria también debe
ser de viabilidad planetaria 2015
también será tuyo esa agenda 2030
global que hablar de seguridad hídrica, pero
los datos dan miedo de la 2.1
mil millones de personas sin acceso al agua
beber 844 millones en tv no aceptado
sin agua y 2.300 millones de personas
no teníamos acceso a saneamiento y nuestra
región
básicamente pensé bien si tenemos que
15 años hasta el 2030 la idea es garantizar esto
acceso y saneamiento al agua para todos
habitantes de la tierra como un derecho
universal y aquí viene la parte necrim
pasa aguanta esta mision asi
intercambio uno puede ayudar en cooperación
transfronterizo y puedo ir
¿Puedo entender cuál es el
mi papel aquí donde estoy parado allí
Empecé a investigar el triple
frontera en el mundo ya tiene más de 270
ríos transfronterizos y cuencas donde 40
por ciento de la población vive, etc.
si pensamos en 2025 tenemos 8
mil millones de personas en la tierra agua y un
elemento de cooperación y estar en el
triple frontera guaraní donde tendrá
una enfermedad respiratoria cataratas
Acuífero Guaraní una de las reservas de
agua dulce más importante del planeta
tierra
ésta es una fotografía de mi familia
la existencia de trabajo
desarrollado en los últimos cinco años
entender que pensar cómo el
iniciativa local de local a global y
¿Cómo puedo escalar y trabajar como yo?
como una persona joven para movilizar esta seguridad
nivel de agua
ubicación internacional pero es como tú
también como él es yo también pero
se sintió solo de alguna manera en 2015
comenzamos con el fundador y también con el
grupo de jóvenes del medio ambiente que
era un programa que cultivaba agua buena era
reunir a deportistas y deportistas es
ingenieros toda la juventud que fue
dentro del programa para trabajar con nosotros
no sé exactamente lo que queríamos
trabajo pero logramos definir esto es
mi participación juvenil y
sustentabilidad
actualmente estamos emitiendo nuevos
ciudades más de 70 jóvenes han sido
formado y trabajado como
liderazgo relacionado con la seguridad
suministro de agua en la región sino también otra
el punto aun no tenia datos o muchos
los datos no estaban disponibles junto con
gente maravillosa como estuvo el
profe Luciano vamos a confundir
observatorio ambiental moema vino a
llegamos a 56 personas al principio
actualmente hay más de 30 personas y
nueve proyectos trabajando también en
aspectos fundamentales como la
construccion de politicas publicas
educación ambiental del municipio después
del asunto porque no podemos
detener la sostenibilidad
si el tema de la educación y vinieron
otras iniciativas como un observatorio
de la política energética estamos en el
lugar que utiliza agua, energía y
la comida y el nexo
Entonces, ¿cómo vamos a trabajar?
a nivel de política de cooperación en
infraestructura y estudiar algunos
parámetros que han sido fundamentales
como la tormenta que estamos haciendo con é
un acuerdo e itaipu
logramos hacer eventos
nacional uno de los mayores eventos con
más de 500 participantes
es el país y los 35 hablantes de
no solo discutir sino crear esta ruta de
trabajo de cooperación local y el resto
lado del paraguay presente para ti
la red es el escombro y el medio ambiente era
empezamos a crear una idea donde
son estos agentes para no
¿Dónde está esta investigación sobre el agua?
dentro del país
tenemos 16 departamentos
participó el año pasado
encontramos una investigación de primer nivel y ahora
estamos contribuyendo a los diferentes
ministerios y este año en dos semanas
tendremos la segunda versión del foro y no
camina sí básicamente donde tienes
crear un equipo para ir al foro
mundo del agua y repensar la agenda
voluntad global virtud sostenibilidad
dentro de la seguridad del agua
nos estamos preparando para el siguiente
foro que esta en senegal
en el año 2021 hay una startup de nicho
denuncia' trabajamos por la alfabetización
energía pero también alfabetización
indica entonces pensar con la compañía de
saneamiento enfermedad paraná no call people
joven te necesitamos
crea tus prospectos los escenarios
prospectivo para trabajar
Yo soy de estas ciudades es la cuestión de
sustentabilidad seguridad hídrica y hay
involucra a muchos actores a nivel de
industria del gobierno e ir a la academia
también al parlamento mundial del agua
sólo representan en el parlamento dentro del
región del mercosur
estamos en más de 80 países es
trabajando con diferentes jóvenes este
problema de acceso agua seguridad agua y
tecnología agua energía agua y alimentos
y tus héroes que me hacen pensar cada
dia cuando el gol de paraguay y brasil
y cuando viajas más, usas más tiempo
mi vida ¿cómo es que todos todavía tenemos
hora
están viendo fotos de los guerreros alrededor
Agua
mucho tiene muchos colegas han dado acceso
para regar a comunidades que no tenían
se que la gente piensa solesia seu
metas globales siendo readem soy yo
Salí del agua cruzando el
desarrollo humano y finalmente
pine presentará una iniciativa que el
blue chips abril pis entiende el agua como
un punto de entrada para la cooperación y
diálogo entre naciones y entre naciones
blue pis fue creado por el fondo de
desarrollo suizo y básicamente el
trabajamos en estos puntos
transfronterizo a nivel global
desde la educación pacífica del agua hasta
ahí por agua blanda y como un sí
estamos pensando en la economía circular
en la responsabilidad planetaria el agua es
un perfecto punto de entrada-salida de
un sistema si esta contaminado la lssca
mar dijo que no lo estamos haciendo bien
politicas no estamos pensando bien es tuyo
derecho universal
trabaja desde el tema de la educación
preservar en los acuíferos y eso fue todo
pensar como un extranjero o
pensamiento extraterrestre cómo
para poder trabajar en estas ideas
que me enseñó en la comisión por dentro
astronomía astrología el territorio
lugar
actualmente con estilo era
pensando en varias otras estrategias
pero lo que importa en este movimiento
somos jóvenes somos los catalizadores
somos el motor como milenios como
objetivo discutir ser más creativos somos
fortaleciendo y moviendo naciones
Te agradezco los espacios que me
permitir que los aficionados también ocupen lo que
me permite que un hacker pueda entrar
y actuar
regionalmente en beso para ti un
maravillosa biografia que es un documento
una cuestión de supervivencia
creado por el grupo que habla jesus como
agua y era un problema pero también cómo
se convirtió en el proyecto de
cooperación transfronteriza y
récord de pacificación te reto
pensó en cómo está trayendo el
límites espacio-temporales de los datos
Las lenguas cíclicas han adquirido un acento y
común también están saliendo en esta zona
de comodidad pero como los jóvenes hay más
hora
estamos dejando espacio para nosotros
somos jóvenes para poder trabajar y
planificar ese futuro de sostenibilidad
planetario
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]